au milieu des tissus et des machines
anne marché prend doucement ses marques
cette couturière en reconversion est
installée ici depuis un mois a laissé
dans un premier temps ça permet de pas
payé le loyer pendant un an de faire un
crash test on peut dire voilà j'ai un an
pour voir si ça tourne ça tombe pas ça
tombe pas j'ai un bail précaire donc
avec le propriétaire ici ça tourne les
pages persévérer ramener de nouveaux
commerces et de l'activité en
centre-bourg
pour le moment les lusignois sont
conquis je trouve ça super pouvoirs si
ça marche et tout fait moi j'étais
entrepreneurs avant puis c'est vrai que
j'aurais bien aimé que ça existe c'est
nécessaire parce qu'on est en
déperdition un petit peu de tout ça et
ça manque parce que les gens change un
petit peu de mentalité gens passent
devant et voit qu'il ya une animation
que c'est plutôt pas mal
à quelques pas cette boutique vide sera
dans quelques semaines un atelier
consacré au vélo
on va présenter les vélos électriques en
location certainement en déprime
pour benoît guennoun la formule est
l'occasion de construire son projet dans
un endroit dédié
j'ai animé un atelier jusqu'à maintenant
deux heures par semaine pour lequel je
rapportais mon matériel donc
effectivement avoir un lieu en fixe
permet d'avoir du matériel en fixe et
nous développer aussi d'autres activités
le concept est un accord entre trois
partenaires le porteur de projet le
propriétaire des lieux qui s'engagent
sur un loyer modéré et la ville qui
apporte des financements le but
insuffler du dynamisme en évitant les
vitrines vides
c'est bénéfique pour un territoire dans
une période difficile il faut montrer
qu'on baisse pas les bras au contraire
qu'on ajoute des choses elle il ya des
clés c'est nous qui les avons trois
projets de boutiques à l'essai sont déjà
lancés à luzy et une 4e pourrait voir le
jour sans tarder avec pour objectif que
tout s'implante à long terme dans
l'année à venir